We're running through the Cognto lab and
we're running through it with the Python
script that you have put up in here.
>> Yeah, the same you should have already
run the CLI and got the client ID
>> and I'm going to need you have the
client ID in order to proceed.
>> Okay,
>> Bash, I'm still looking at your uh
GitHubs.
I should probably finish it tonight.
>> Appreciate that.
I was looking for you.
>> Yeah, it took me a little while to get
home to get in time, but I just got here
now.
>> Oh, it's okay. I was in Houston.
Wait, this the same read me.
Okay.
Okay, cool.
I can pay.
What's today? Tuesday.
That's a good news, babe.
So I can go to Japan and rip there as
long as I don't get a salary.
So you work for free?
>> No, I have to I can't get a salary from
Japan.
>> Like I can only go there for a while and
then because I like if I'm like a
traveling if I'm internal company going
to Japan that that's normal. But if I
stay there for a certain period of time
and I'm not paying taxes to the Japanese
government.
So yeah.
missing. What are you missing, coach?
What are you missing?
>> All right. So, after a specific period
of time, you become like a tax resident
there in Japan. Is that what you're
saying? And you have to pay you have to
basically cough up the the dope.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, if I'm working in Japan, well, so
if I do like if I'm a remote worker, but
I'm actually on site working, I can only
do that for a certain period of time.
collection
>> app client must not have a client secret
enabled.
>> That's right. So, do what you did
before. It's the same thing that you
guys did before. Just make sure that you
don't have the client because that's the
secret path.
>> Except I do. So, I'm going to need to do
that over again, huh?
>> Wow.
Wow.
>> Okay. You can make another app client.
Should be fun.
Oh,
provide your own secret client.
Wait a minute.
All
right.
Uh if you do a machine to machine
instead of a traditional application
that allows you to do that allows you to
not configurate
um client secret. As far as I'm aware,
it's telling me secret is still
required.
Um, would a single page application
work?
That's the only option we got left. Run
it.
This one's Tuesday.
All right.
Login page unavailable.
That was the first one.
I'm doing some um Google searching.
>> Yeah, I'm looking through documentation
right now.
Yeah. Why don't you use um traditional?
>> You want traditional?
>> Yeah.
>> But traditional wants us to enter a
client secret if we disable the toggle.
>> Try with that.
This is it.
>> The first one we made had the client
secret. We're going to create a new one.
Traditional
if I don't generate one.
Yep.
>> Still won't let me do it.
custom.
Put it in a put in a custom plan.
>> That's fine. Try ABC123.
ABC123 on
>> it's too short.
>> It's got to be 18 or 24 to 64 characters
long.
>> Okay, then
um make one.
>> Uhuh. All right, cool.
That's 10.
>> a public client doesn't have a secret.
>> Right. But so that's the thing I'm
reading in the document here. Let me
pull up this documentation.
Put it here.
So they go through
public clients and everything.
They go through the different app client
types.
and then give you some information on
how to protect it using CloudFront
proxy. But they don't go into
at least not on this one. They don't go
into how to set one up.
>> Uh I think it's SPA
>> cuz we're doing this all console based,
right?
So my next question, Theo, when it says
Unless you want hell, the app client
must not be enabled.
What does that hell look like?
>> Remember,
>> sorry.
>> Remember we did in the class? We did the
secret hash. Remember, guys, remember
when you guys had to figure out the
secret hash, right?
>> Yep.
>> Was that fine?
>> Ah, yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep.
>> All right.
>> No. I'll sort this out.
Let's see what else is out there.
>> Secret hash or leisel
takes 15 minutes, but this the stank
will never leave your mind.
Or doing a secret hash, but the
computation will never leave your mind.
Either way, you're defiled.
Such is life.
Let me try something.
Let me try it. See
Yeah, I believe those were the four
Quiet.
I
don't
Okay.
Yeah.
This one's not going to work.
What?
Okay. All right.
He failed again.
Single page.
We wa na ma number one.
Oh, that's right.
Just
been created. You've got no client
secret attached.
Can I view your login page? I still
cannot.
It's concealable error.
pack overflow. What are you saying?
password is passwordless.
I need a pass key.
Okay. Um, I think I figured it out.
>> Who's speaking?
>> Uh, Kevin.
>> All right, Kevin.
>> All right. What's
What's the word? All right, let's try
this. Um,
go back to your user pools.
>> Um, click on that one.
Then on the left hand side, scroll down
and click on managed login. Um, it's
under the branding section.
Yeah. And then from here,
um, click on Yeah. Click there the style
ID and then click on view login page. I
mean we could try it.
>> I don't know if this is just like a mock
or but it looks like it responds.
>> Yeah, user pool.
>> It works. Kevin, I just tested it right
now. Um if you go to create sty
allow you to did it already have a style
attached. Okay. All right. Yeah, it's
the default style.
>> One second.
>> I meant on the spa. On the spa, if you
do that, it will uh it will allow you to
go to the login page without secret.
>> I think this one isn't um let me check.
>> Yes.
I think it was this one.
Yeah, it's that manage login on the left
and then go down. Yeah, where it says
create a style on the right
and then go to Webeyama. Click on that.
Yeah. and then create.
Okay, now you can go back to app plats
or yeah, if you log page versus
>> work. There you go.
>> All right, there sir. I appreciate it.
Let me put some notes on this real
quick. Okay.
Yeah, good looking out, man, Kevin.
Yeah, you are actually right on that. I
just uh I just got to the to that point
a bit quicker, but yeah,
>> you you were literally on the right
path.
>> Well, thank Reddit.
>> Yeah, good.
All right.
Oh, okay.
That is true. Yeah, I got the same.
>> That is very true.
What am I doing? This is what you're
doing.
Oh, he's not added to anything. So,
do I need to delete Victor?
>> Um, did you did you try changing the
email? Assuming you have multiple email
addresses.
>> Yeah, you're not wrong.
You're not wrong.
Let's try.
>> Oh, hey CAD. What? Oh, sorry. Pardon my
language while I'm recording. So,
okay.
>> Yeah. Um, if you click on the gear icon,
um,
you'd be able So, uh, sorry, my bad.
Um, I think if you just click on the use
on Victor,
you should be able to change the email
address from there.
Yeah. Um, edit. Yeah, there you go.
I'm going to try this one.
market is verified.
Save me an extra step.
Right
now, I think we need to
we should probably try to test login
first before we add MFA.
Lemon is the winner.
See if that'll do.
Nope.
User still not confirmed.
Hold on. Let me see something
cuz this might be redundant.
If it still work
email verify confirmation status is
still unconfirmed.
I think I'm going to test this myself
before I suggested but under users if
you click on Victor for example
and then click on actions
there is a confirm account. Um so I'm
going to try that first as the Oh okay I
guess you want to do it too.
>> Thank you.
>> Yep.
I was reading a resend confirmation code
documentation for user pools. I like
this better.
Okay, my guy
Victor
authenticator
I'm stunned.
Victor, you're in there.
Okay.
with that.
Oh, I take it. We're going straight to
this Python now.
Uh uh uh uh client ID replace client ID.
Client agent replace client agent
username, password.
So I'm going to go ahead
pop this baby up.
Uh
what we call it this easy
token.
Okay.
Okay, user input is going to be popped
up to us. So before I do that, I need to
actually go in and put in
here.
What am I saying?
Evan Java client ID.
Username
Victor
password
that in there.
Haha. Authentication failed.
Well, then
did I get that right?
I'm going to move this here.
Yep. I'm in North Virginia.
Okay.
If response gets challenged name SMS
MFA,
we can't use SMS MFA if we don't have
SMS MFA set up.
We obviously have to change it.
>> Yeah.
Which one are we using?
Y
>> software token MFA.
>> Thank you. Sorry, I'm closing off a
bunch of the tabs real quick.
Damn. See
What was the error on this? Missing
required parameter software token MFA
code.
You see where it says yeah SMS MFA code
change it to software token MFA code.
Save and fire up.
All right. Nice and easy.
>> Hooray.
>> Thanks for the help, fellas.
>> So good.
>> Yes, sir.
We got the token. Great.
Hold
on.
Pop you up over here.
API gateway. I don't know why for the
life of me I didn't pick my biggest
monitor to share. I'm going to change
that right now.
I can split a couple of things up that
way.
have an authorizer on it.
What we call it
taco Tuesday prod whatever
deploy.
Oh, I
want a
So I did that.
Thank you.
What do I do?
It's a good man.
source.
Great.
That's dead.
Hey, the uh your paste for the author.
Oh, never mind. You're erasing it. Um
the easier way the easier way to do that
is to do uh dollar sign access token
equals and then paste all that baloney.
>> Exactly what I'm about to do.
>> Yeah.
Whatever.
>> Well, not dollar sign access token. I
mean access token.
>> Access token equals value and then call
it back that way.
>> Yeah.
>> And sometimes when it adds a 200 in
front.
>> So you got to be careful about that.
>> Yeah.
Not anymore. I don't
>> gotcha.
Okay.
What did I miss?
Authorization header requires credential
parameter. Authorization header requires
signature parameter site headers
perimeter. This is either or date
header.
They give us the teachers of his
majesty.
We know what
it
was the time on
That ain't going to do nothing.
Why is that so stuck in my head?
Yeah. So I thought Okay.
Right in front of you.
Oh,
dead. Okay,
that makes so much sense.
Uh, didn't I have you up already?
Could have sworn I did.
Yeah, that's why
She did that even change.
Shouldn't have.
I shouldn't have.
Okay.
Ed. Okay. A working
No,
Hey, did you make sure you have uh
your on your edit method request you
have that AWS Cognto sign in user admin
as the authorization scope?
Ah yes
otherwise no bill.
Wait,
why still mailed
civil?
Okay, whatever. I'll deal with that
shortly.
I have everything I need here.
>> No, you're good there.
>> I'm good there.
>> Okay. So, go back to API gateway.
>> Yeah.
say it's added there.
Yeah. Request validator.
>> No, that was Hold on.
>> Yeah, you don't bother with that. Yeah.
Okay. So, is that the correct
authorization?
>> Yeah.
>> Hit save.
>> Yep. That's it. AWS signing user admin.
Boom.
was a capital.
I should probably get a new token
though.
>> No, you you got an hour.
>> Okay.
Arta.
The hell do I care about art?
I know that I was in there.
Boom.
Credential parameter. Signature
parameter.
Wait.
What are you getting?
Okay.
Okay. Let's see.
Thank you.
Are you running through the lab again?
>> Sorry.
>> Are you running through the lab again?
>> I'm just playing around with a couple
different um
Oh,
>> where was it?
>> Yeah, I'm just trying to catch up.
>> Where are you?
Um, so I have the access token
and I think I just need to
um I should have the authorizer, but I
should probably check that with this API
gateway. I'm pretty sure it's the same
one I used on Saturday.
I could share my screen if you want.
Yeah, sure. If you'd like. You're
definitely going to need to change some
stuff. Or maybe not. I don't know. Let's
see.
>> All right. Let's Let's do it. Um I think
it's this one.
All right. Um
can you see my screen?
>> Hold on. I'm moving you back to the big
screen. Okay.
Yep.
>> Hey,
this was the authorizer um I used on
Saturday.
I'll just click on edit so you can see
it.
I think everything looks good here.
Ardino sighting user admin
and then
>> okay
>> I don't think he did anything for the
request validator
then
it's or
yeah, so it should be this. So this
should work in theory.
And the Python version is using the
same.
Oh, you know what? Oh, hold on. That
won't work.
That would not work.
No, actually, yeah, it's it's the same
it's the same pool. Okay.
Okay.
So, now I think all I just need to do is
the curl. Is that correct?
Give it a try. Okay.
>> Go back.
There we go.
And we're visual studio.
Okay. So, we curl.
We're just going to do it without the
token.
Okay. Unauthorized.
And then girl
H.
Oh no. What did I do? Huh?
Internal server error.
See?
Yeah.
You know what? No, I think it's I think
it's a different URL actually.
Just going to clear this.
I think it was
name equals
And then
Oh, you doesn't like this one for some
reason.
Did you um try with the with the query
parameter?
just for kicks.
>> Yeah,
>> drop that in your browser and see what
pops up.
>> Okay.
And if I
just remove the last bit of it
actually beneath this.
Yeah,
still the same.
Did you So, okay, cuz we kind of hopped
in a little bit halfway through. Is this
off of a new
app client that you made today or did
you have the same one up from
>> This one is a
Yeah, brand new.
>> Brand new one. Okay. And then
>> wait, give me
Okay. Yeah, it's Yeah, this app client.
Okay.
Go to your authorizer and then Yeah, you
got it there.
>> I can create a new one. Just
>> make a new one just for us.
Neato
and let's go back cuz I have several
have several of these
JD. Okay.
JD E RK.
Yep. This one in the middle.
Then I think this was authorization.
Okay.
Should probably try to test this.
H
maybe my user pool is the issue.
See
There you go.
>> Change this one.
>> Do the same there. Deploy it and then
wait a few minutes.
>> Okay.
Okay.
>> Got to breathe a little bit.
>> Okay.
All
right, Calvin, go for it. All right,
we're just going to just leave it like
this for now.
Okay.
This is new.
>> Yeah, I think you got a similar issue to
me. I think you forgot to add the
slash Python
>> question mark aspect. Yeah,
>> we'll try that.
>> I think you still need the question mark
uh name equals something.
Yes.
Put a space when you type in
authorization colon. Put a space before
you enter the um
>> Okay.
27.
Does he need to put the token in single
quotations because maybe it's viewing it
as a needs to see it as a string since
we're not using a variable.
>> I could try that.
Wouldn't hurt.
>> All right. Really stupid question. Um,
you're using Zshell.
Shouldn't it be bash?
>> Oh, I'm I'm on a Mac.
Can't you run a bash shell on a Mac?
>> I've never tried it.
>> You can just type bash. It'll drop. It
should drop you into a bash shell.
They're pretty much the same though
except for some of the edge case
commands.
>> Just humor me.
>> I'm just gonna grab like
>> highlight the whole run bash. Start bash
first.
Okay.
>> Okay. Now run that whole plan again.
>> Okay. You should Okay, I don't have the
history. Okay, that's fine.
Just going to put this
here.
That's a question mark.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Let me zoom in.
We go. Gotcha.
>> Single or double quotation for bash.
>> Uh, try double quotes. That's what I
have.
>> Okay.
And that would be
this lovely piece of
here.
Okay,
it works. Yay.
>> Damn it, Max.
>> All right, so then um
the
Okay, there we go.
Then the um the node should also work
and
>> Yep.
>> So why didn't it work with um ZH
um H? Is it because
um
is it because it reads the double
quotation marks differently?
>> That I don't know. I don't see any
passion.
But normally I I would set the huge long
string as a uh
environment variable.
>> It works.
>> There we go. All right.
I'm convinced to use bash from now on.
>> I do have a quick question. Uh when you
guys created the app, did you guys use
the single app application? The SBA?
>> So what we did,
>> where is that?
>> Yes, we definitely use the single page
app.
>> Okay.
>> And then you go down here.
>> Yeah. And add the style.
>> Yep. Add the style.
Um you have the second one here. And
then click on view login page. Yeah,
you'll get you'll get this. Okay.
>> All right. Thanks, guys.
Anyone
else um is running into issues?
If y'all want, I can share my screen.
Okay, that's fine. Mine
>> I I did some modifications to the
script.
Is that it? It's all yours.
>> Okay, hold on.
There's my mouse
share.
>> So, I made some tweaks.
Um,
so instead of typing in
the password and username every time, I
decided to set environment variables and
have that pulled in that time. So
over here,
client ID, client secret,
username and password, secret hash,
client ID, secret hash, username and
password.
And then here you can as O parameters
you can actually pass secret hash. So I
did so I didn't have to create another
app client.
But uh secret hash is computed with this
fancy shindig over here.
That's what I did from last week.
I'll copy it in the chat. Hold on. Copy.
Okay. And then uh you you well for
everybody everybody has to do this but
you have to change it from SMS
MFA token to software token. So I did
that then pass the secret hash again and
it spits it out.
So all I have to do is enter the MFA
code and it spits out all the stuff.
questions, comments.
I'm not trying to show off. I'm just,
hey, I just did it a slightly different
way.
>> Anybody there? Hello?
>> That was pretty cool. Yeah,
>> it seems that they have it down. So,
yeah, they're fine.
>> I mean, it's not much different. It's
just slightly different.
>> This is the main part that's different
>> right here.
>> At this age, you should be strong. You
should not be looking
for
But
>> anyway,
>> it's still a it's still a private
client, isn't it? You use the
traditional web app.
>> Uh I don't know actually. How do I find
that out?
>> Um when you set up the the app client,
did you use traditional or did you use
another option?
>> Hold on. Let me go to Cognto and look.
NATO
>> pool.
>> Okay. I mean, well, we got it done
anyway. But I mean, it's
>> this one. Yeah.
>> Allow user password off. Yeah, it's
turned on. So that's probably what I
did.
>> Yeah, that's why it's working. We did
another way. We did it without the
client.
>> Yeah. So we had to use uh we had to make
a public client.
>> Um but we use SPA and then we had to
attach a style so that even the login
page would even show up because nothing
is configured. We don't we're not really
configuring SP. So
>> um
>> okay. And then
>> yeah,
>> we had to go the long way around. But
this is also a way to do it as well. If
we didn't have the constraint that we're
not allowed to use the client secret
for us, but apart from that, yeah, this
way works as well.
>> Gotcha. Yeah, I think we tried user off
first and you had to basically grab two
session keys before you could get in. I
was like, let me put it on the user
password off and
that's what I've been using since. And
the and the code, the Python script is
set to user password off anyway. So,
>> anyway, uh that's what I have. I will
unshare my screen now.
>> Good stuff. Good stuff.
asked
for.
>> Is there anyone else who has not who has
not tried to use the script yet?
Okay. Watch.
>> Boom. Push.
>> Sold. All right. So, they're fine. Phil,
what else do you want to do?
Not bad.
I'm watching this. Well,
>> okay.
How' you like it so far?
>> This is
>> Yeah, I just had a quick question
because I I saw there was another Python
script. What's the
Is that just another way of doing the
same thing we just did or is that
another for a different use case?
>> Try it.
>> Go ahead and do it.
>> Share screen. Let's help you. Wait, did
you did you follow through what people
were doing?
>> Yeah, I got
>> I got the easy token to work.
>> Okay. All right. So, yeah. So, it
worked, right? So, then the Python
script. Go ahead. do it just so you
could see what I was doing. I have a
little fun with that one.
>> Okay, let me uh
share here. Let me close down some of
these tabs.
>> Okay.
I'm assuming it's not an issue to put it
in the same folder to run.
We have to.
I mean, if you do though, is it 18 years
of child support?
>> No, it is not.
>> Then you could do what you want.
18 January 1st applies to you as well.
>> That is true.
>> I mean, the date's different if you were
in Texas.
>> Oh, no. No. Okay. Texas. Yeah. Yeah.
Texas. It didn't work until the the
union came in and kicked the people's
ass. Basically 19. Wait, I know. I know.
The the the capital is It says it right
there. I mean, it's on the plaque. Have
you seen it in Austin?
>> Oh, they put a plaque for it.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
So, I'll replace the API
code and then client ID.
Yeah, Austin really isn't like Texas
really isn't the south. It kind of is,
but it's really not. It's really It
really operates like a different
country.
So does um uh California.
I find that the closer I get to the
border, the more America it becomes.
But the further away, man, that this
place is not the America. It's like it's
just kind of different.
>> I like it here, though.
>> It's no Japan, that's for sure.
Oh, it's definitely not Japan. But Japan
has a different
mentality, different way of doing
everything.
>> I want to go back.
Well, when I cross the border, like when
I go to Arkansas or Louisiana, I
automatically the first thing I think
is, "Oh, yeah. I'm in America.
This This is the reality." But when I go
to Houston,
>> go south.
>> No, no, it's No. I mean, it's America.
It feels like America.
>> Not just the South, it's states.
But when I go to Houston, I start
feeling like I the America feeling
starts.
So that's why because it's getting
closer to the border.
>> What do you identify as feeling like
America?
>> Let's just say that the states, the
continental states and Texas and um
California are different.
It's done. No, it's different vibe.
Different way of doing things.
>> I guess it's like Boston's the central
mass.
>> No. No. Boston was America.
I do feel the states there.
>> Oh, central mass is real real fun.
>> New York. Well, New York New York New
York New York New York New York New York
New York New York New York was was
America with a with an attitude with a
really bad attitude.
No, what what was that? What did what
did that what did that what did that
script do?
>> Um,
appears that it instead of us having to
type in the curl command, it went ahead
and tested both endpoints.
And since they were reached, it put
done.
>> Oh, was that
>> I am curious though because it doesn't
have the
the other part that we usually put in.
>> Yeah, it just gives you the the the easy
parts. It doesn't Yeah, it doesn't part.
It didn't append the uh question mark
query stuff. So, you have it just makes
it easier to copy and paste. you still
have to add the uh question mark name
equals blah blah blah
>> but this
>> okay
>> yeah so we're going to be using this
script in variations
>> you know for next
>> that uh the token code is pretty cool
that
>> just so you know this these two scripts
are going to be used for um the basis of
Armageddon that's
See, so it's already it's already
started,
right? Yeah, I agree, Omar. Texas is not
the South. It's It's not It's not the
states. When When Northerners start
talking about a civil war, I said,
"Look, I sit back and said like, do you
really want to fight Texas? Like, are
you sure?"
I mean,
>> Texas and Florida together. Jeez. Just
Texas by itself. The amount of industry,
everybody's armed bullets, they can
shoot.
We have food sources. We have our own
electric grid. So hopefully it doesn't
go out.
I mean,
>> isn't Texas like the sixth highest geo
or GDP in the world right now?
>> No. Florida is.
>> Florida is.
>> Yeah. So Texas got to be higher than six
then.
>> No, no, no, it's not. It doesn't have
it. It's only 32 million. I think
California's over 40. Um
I think that uh what
Texas I think is in top 10 though by
itself.
We keep on getting people here all the
time.
Again, it's it's being in Texas is kind
of complicating me to leave the country.
I do want to leave the country, but it's
>> Texas isn't a bad situation. I won't
date here, but oo the money is it's kind
of there's some nice things about Texas.
It's
it's not not entirely like if I were in
Illinois, I'd be like, "Fuck this [ __ ]
I'm out of here. Get the hell out of the
way." California. [ __ ] it. I I have to
shoot my way to LAX. I'll get I'll get
I'm leaving it. [ __ ] it. But uh Texas is
not not like that. It's not not the
same.
There you go.
All right.
All
right.
Hey guys. So,
>> I was playing around with it.
>> No, no, I like I like what you're doing.
Yeah. No, I I understand.
>> Yeah,
>> it's a good way of doing it. Um, I might
modify that, but that that's a good
idea. I went to Okay. Um,
let me go ahead so you guys can see.
Um,
you guys can see what we're what we're
doing there. We don't don't have that
much time left. So, let me go ahead and
show this to you. What this is um lesson
F,
okay, if you guys want to see what's
coming down next to the pipeline. And
this is with Dynamo DB. Okay. So,
what you're going to do is you go
through here in Dynamo DB is you're
going to uh talk about with a token
whether or not it's been used or not.
And if it hasn't been used in in a
certain period of time, it'll fire off
an alert to an event bridge.
And so there are u modifications to the
script that you have to take you have to
do but this is going to be the first
event bridge. So I wanted to introduce a
script to you guys today uh because
we're the script is going to be
important for how we're going to be
doing the the the beginning of event
driven architectures. Okay.
So look at the script and uh do play
around with it or we're going to do this
on Saturday and Sunday to the same going
to continue on but this is this part is
going to be cool. So next week is Dynamo
DB and
um uh what event broach.
Okay,
any questions about this so far?
Any
questions, comments?
>> I get some. There's background noise.
Sounds good, British.
>> All right. Is this better? Can you hear
me now?
>> Okay, now it sounds better.
>> Okay. Um, you were saying that these
balls would be the basis of Armageddon.
Were you referring to the Python and
NodeJS file for lambda?
>> What we did today?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Focus on what we did today.
>> Right. What I did today, this is the
start. So, I want what I want you to do
is just look at the repos.
Just make sure you start knowing them
because I'm I'm suddenly going to pop a
little nothing.
Uh Rob, what's up?
>> If you had to um
if you had to weigh your um you know
your your v your skill set which is very
which is varied
um how important would systems design be
in your skill set?
>> Huge.
I think about systems design all the
time.
So when I'm doing like Armageddon right
now, the reason why I'm not
I'm not ready. I don't have it all there
because I'm still designing,
but I'm pushing I'm pushing my design as
far as I possibly can. So there's a lot
of different parts in there. The
difference is is that I'm using Bedrock.
So it's it's coming from an AI security
platform engineering point of view. So
how do I how do I implement bedrock in
there and there's things I haven't done
before like there's this theoretical
architectures that I have but this is
very similar to what I was doing in the
in the beginning of cloud
back six years ago during um the
pandemic.
So it's kind of fun. It's also kind of
stressful.
Um, I have to make sure that Bedrock can
work accordingly and that that the rack
can work accordingly as well. But there
is
there's a super lab coming.
That's all I can say to you guys.
There's something out of this world.
Like even I look at I was in the car and
I was doing the formation of it. I was
like, damn, where'd that come from?
Where where'd you get that?
Where did you get your foundations for
systems design? Was it Cisco?
>> Cisco.
>> Yeah.
>> You're always thinking about different
things in Cisco like how do you connect
here to there and then then this
application how does it connect to this
application? And it's not so much the
API that's the key. The the API is cute.
is how do you route the traffic and then
then
you're like think about data center and
then VLANs how the architecture works
and then once you understand that that
it's
when you're getting stuff like this in
the cloud this is simple this is easy
stuff
that's all got it's it's all Cisco
um Omar
>> yeah I have a couple concerns from some
brothers about going from
I guess zero knowledge, never doing this
stuff before, getting into a senior
level role. What's what's your thoughts?
What's what's your comments on them
being concerned about that?
>> They need to give their concern
specifically first, then we can address
each concern specifically.
>> If it's general, then if it's a general
concern, we're going to say you're here.
You this is a program. this is a a a
path that we've paved for people and
they still have issues,
>> then they need to ask them in
particular.
>> So, if they're freshman coming in to
university and they're thinking, well, I
don't know about getting a job. Well,
you haven't graduated yet, [ __ ]
You haven't taken fourth year classes
yet. So, the students who are thinking
this way, the first thing they think is,
did you pass Armageddon? Did you get a
C? There's three searchs that are
necessary. Did you actually get any of
them? Have you read a book? Have we done
neurodymies? That's just what you focus
on right there.
Don't think of anything else. And if
they if they're thinking anything else,
just say, "Look, you're not qualified to
get a job. You're not doing anything to
get take the steps to get a job. If you
stay where you are, you will die."
I had the same mentality towards the
students who start who sit there and
think about AI and then they think AI's
got to take all the jobs. I remember
that in Houston how frustrating that
was.
Dude, there are oh my god. See, I now I
see the other side of how how AI is
going to work. There are going to be so
many freaking jobs. This is going to
freaking like change the economy.
We're we're barely even starting. This
is such a it's a cute little thing right
now. So if you got guys in your class
who like in your group who are like,
"Hold what about AI is going to do my
job?" I just tell them, "Okay, what city
are you in? What's the tallest building?
Okay, go to the top of it and jump off."
Why live?
For anyone listening on the recording,
deal is not advertising for you to jump
off a building.
I got
>> Theo I got guys every day just out in
the regular world that are so scared
that the AI is going to take their job.
Just just in the regular streets that I
meet them,
>> man. Let them be scared. I don't mind.
I really don't you know like I had to
legit legal disclaimer. Um I had to go I
had to face my own issues with this but
I I did it by pressing ahead and
studying it. I mean PyTorch, do they
have a PyTorch book?
Applied machine learning. Do they have
applied machine learning book? Are they
studying
multi- aent system?
Okay, this is one of right now the
resources to learn AI is the best that
I've ever had in my life. The resources
to learn AI two years ago were [ __ ]
I was frustrated. Last year it started
to get a little bit better. This year
it's holy, holy, this is good. There's
all kinds of stuff we can do. There's
all kinds of resources. I understand how
the platform I have all kinds of
assistance. Before it was nothing. So if
they were just worried about it,
this was I just say go ahead and sit
there and die.
>> Hey Rob. Rob, are you still there?
Brother Rob. I mean, deal deals there,
but
>> Well, no. No, no. I'm saying you might
want to make another appearance on the
unwind because there's a lot of brothers
that
>> they they they think things, but they
don't want to say it out loud, so I got
to say it. So, I'm just telling
>> they fear things, they're not doing
their homework. That's what it comes
down to.
>> Yeah.
>> Did you do your homework? Right.
>> Well, I mean, it's it's just it's just a
growing concern of of of wondering is it
possible to go from zero to to a senior
developer position? Not developer, but a
senior
>> got over people who've done it in the
class in the group.
>> You got you got someone who joined this
class and under a year he got a job.
>> Yep.
>> For for anyone who puts in Okay.
You you you you called me Omar, right?
And you you asked me like, "Hey, we need
guys to prove that they're actually
getting there because they want proof."
Cool. We provide proof. If
I mean,
thank you again for bringing their
concerns up, but at what point do they
believe what we're showing them?
Because if you got Theo who changed his
entire career within like you know 3 4
years
you know from from networking to you
know ARM to you know systems admin stuff
and then he found the cloud read a sands
course saw dev sec ops and then [ __ ] his
entire insight overnight and then he got
felons hired He got number of classes
that are trained people and from no
fault of his own people who have fallen
off or if they haven't fallen off then
they're closer to getting a job. If they
follow what he's saying and if they
follow what we've laid out then it can
work. If they have questions then are
they asking them to you to the group
leader to CPG guys to anybody? If I mean
it it it can't it can't come from me and
it can't come from Theo every single
time. And this is why I posted Ric Flair
in the battle backyard. Do you believe
that you are? Can you say that word? I
am a cloud engineer. Can you say that?
If you can't say that, if you can't
believe that, then you are you've
already lost because you're still
doubting whether you can actually do
this. If you doubt yourself, you're even
you're making it harder for yourself to
even take that first step.
I don't know. It didn't happen. Well,
hey, man. Hey, if it didn't, it did.
Take me. I I came into it be like when I
was in college. I'm I'm with Theo now. I
went my entire I went 10 almost like
what 10 almost 10 years of working in IT
before I came to this class and I've
been in this class for 3 years and I've
been here for this long because I see
the vision and I see what can be done.
This is the be I'll say I keep saying
it. This is the best fast track that you
could ever hope for to get from zero to
100. And if and if these people doubt
it, then they can feel free to go pay
for uh uh uh Nana, pay $1,800 and take
her DevOps course and then pay another
$1,800 and pay for a dev sec ops course
and she'll teach you the exact same
thing. But maybe they'll listen because
that's a woman. I don't know. Like
I don't know.
>> They still pro Well, first they wouldn't
watch Nana. They wouldn't do the
homework. They wouldn't read. And if you
don't do that, that's a death sentence.
It's not gonna work. So that they would
probably just sit there and say, "How
can we how can a man do how can that be
possible?" And this is like, "Hey, look,
the world's going to keep on going. You
can stay right here."
You can't have any mercy. You just have
to keep on going. I I I I don't care. I
mean, I got I got guys from high school.
I have friends from high school who are
complaining about not getting jobs
because all they did was learn Python
and they stopped upgrading their skills
from there.
I'm looking at I'm like, you're one of
the smartest people I know. You just did
Python and that's it. You stop and now
you complain you can't get a job. Are
you kidding me? No, man.
The
>> How many hours per day? Hey, how many
hours per day, Theo, you think is is
minimum they should be putting in doing
this?
The more they put in, the faster they'll
get out of the faster they'll get out of
whatever situation they're in.
>> Serge used to joke four hours a day
minimum.
>> But
>> right and and right now Serge is getting
recruited by uh Warner Brothers for a
job.
>> Oh, I should tell them about it. Okay,
that's one of um
>> Well, they they got they got mad at me
when I said four hours.
You you told them you told them and what
they do. They're they're fighting
themselves.
We can't if you know if you again like
you you are you you already know the
answer, Omar, cuz you've been in this,
right? You've done the work. You know
what the deal is. Even if you're not
employed and crowded, you still know the
deal. If you're telling them the the
real deal and they're not listening to
you, what are you supposed to do? It's
not you can't change their mind. And and
if you if if the game is the same, the
game don't change. You told them the
game, what makes it different coming
from me or Theo?
>> No. Nothing.
So you have to sit back and say, "Hey,
look here. I'm teaching what to do if
you don't follow it. The bone keeps on
going." As I've told Rob many times, I
have no problems throwing bodies off a
penarch.
>> Don't do it. Don't do it. No. No. No.
And I just I just want to do I just want
to do a shameless plug for this weekend.
I am doing a time management workshop.
I'm doing a free time management
workshop
>> featuring Google calendar and Pomodoro
timer. So if anybody's interested, I
will be posting free workshop. Manage
your time. A lot of people think that
there's not enough time in the day.
>> That's what they're telling me. There's
not enough time in the day.
>> There is definitely enough time in the
day. Um, I I again, shout out to you. I
I I don't I want to acknowledge what
you're doing and I respect it and I
really appreciate what you guys are
doing for what you're doing, Omar, for
these guys. However, no matter any no
matter the uh the techniques, the uh the
the methods, the cheats, the
documentation, no matter what you give
them, no matter what you put in front of
them, they have to actually decide in
their head and in their heart, in their
soul, every fiber of their being that
they can actually do this stuff because
there because ultimately What they're
looking for is validation and motivation
that comes externally.
They don't have they don't have the
discipline to do it. So they're looking
for any other way to say that hey I can
actually get it done.
And and and you know that's and I'm not
saying that people have to have
discipline to come in. But what I'm
saying is discipline to a person who has
not had to ex prove themselves to this
level, it's tough. It rightfully so it
is. So that's why it they have to build
that up. That's why we put guys inside
of CPG because you need the small wins
and you need to get that that
infrastructure that foundation down so
that now you can understand the harder
stuff or you could be allowed to go into
the wild of the homework land and figure
it out. It is it can't it no matter how
many like pomodoro technique or time
management seminars you give ultimately
so if someone really wants to do it
they'll figure out a a way to do it. I
remember um I'll say this and I'll step
back. I remember a dude that um
uh shout out to one of Theo's uh uh uh
former students Dennis Bell. Okay. Um
>> Oh Dennis. Yeah. He Dennis is a monster
out of um out of the uh Jamaica, right?
He's a Azure guy and he brought in his
own homeboy. His homeboy's name is uh
Dimmitri and his also Jamaican. So
Dimmitri had a schedule and this is
pinned inside of Zion. He had a schedule
and he said 500 a.m. I'm waking up. I'm
going to study. Then I'm going to go on
a B. Then I'm going to go walk. Then I'm
going to go pray. Then I'm going to go
back in and study. Then I'm going to go
walk. Then I'm going to go pray. Then
I'm going to take notes. Then I'm going
to watch a video. Then I'm going to do
more work. Then I'm going to go study.
Then I'm going to go pray. Like yes,
Jamaican Demetri. Like that's the that's
the type of stuff that and no one needed
to tell him that what he what he uh had
to do. He had a guy in uh Dennis that
followed the system and he did and and
he followed the system and got uh a CCP
and he called his CCP the certified
Colombana penetrator. Okay, there's
there are videos of him in Colombia
hanging out with chicks,
>> right? But and then he went to Azure
because Jamaica was asking for Azure. So
he did Azure on his own and then he
taught Azure and then Dennis taught
Azure to Dmitri got De told Dmitri to do
these things. Dmitri followed the script
got theerts got into the job now
Dimmitri's working and that was a year
of some change. So
if so if
if someone says that there's not a
direct path or there's not a you know
it's not clear
that's a matter of them being willing to
look into the class see who's available
and ask the question and then absorb it
and act on the information that was
absorbed. You're giving them all the
information, but they're not but it
doesn't seem like they're absorbing it
or they're acting on what they absorb.
They're just receiving it.
>> They're not trying to absorb it. They're
not trying to No, they're not they're
not they're just not trying to absorb
it. That's all it is.
You have to say like, "Hey, look, what's
your effort?" That's why I'm not I'm not
giving any mercy. And um
again, the first student who got a job
in the class, he was already making
$60,000 a year. Um he had been there for
many, many years at 60,000. He got the
CCP. I told him what to do. He went from
60,000 to 320
um in two months, something like that.
And then he went to 360 afterwards.
He gave me very great information about
what he's still at that level. Hasn't
stopped. Um, another guy say his name.
>> He's been there for like what? Three,
four years now.
>> Oh, at least. No, four four and a half.
>> That's Ryan, right?
>> No, not Ryan.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Ryan's at about 175. He's He only got
one job. 175. He's good. He bought a
house. He's good.
>> Yep.
>> Nice.
>> There's another guy, the second guy. His
situation was horrible. very similar to
what I mine was in Japan before I got
into it. He was willing to do anything.
Literally, his situation, what his
living situation in America was abysmal.
I told him what to do. I told him how to
study Python with UDMI. I told him how
to get the skill set. He went from
$20,000 a year to $225,000
within six within 18 months. M
>> so he went from 20,000 to 150 first then
he left the country then he went from
150 to 275
>> on one job or two?
>> Yeah, two jobs.
>> Nice.
>> Never looked back. He's the only student
who wrote me a letter in Japanese visi
Japan from Yokohama.
>> I know you're talking about nice.
>> I told him I told him where to go. He's
still working. He never wants to return
to the United States again. Adamant.
See th those are the guys. They're
they're like, "Hey, what do I have to
do?" I always know I got someone who's
who's aggressive who really wants to
absorb it because they're they won't
leave me alone. They'll say, "What about
this? Can I read this? Can I read that?
How about that? Go to the manga. Go over
there. Got reference over there. Get the
That's me. Go over there." Right? So,
they're always asking for references.
Um, if they're not asking for materials,
they're not asking for white papers, and
asking how do I do this?
Again, I'm a group leader myself. So,
this this time I'm actually a group
leader. I had a guy wake me up last
night at 1:30 in the morning.
I was like, my goodness, are you
serious? So, I had to get Eva off my
arm,
bring over my iPad, and sit there and
teach him terraform
for one hour.
at 1:30 a.m.
Think he's going to be successful?
>> I didn't.
>> Did he look at the recordings?
>> No, I told him what to do. You know
what's kind of funny?
>> He did Terraform correctly, but he
didn't think it was correct.
>> So, I didn't tell him. I I didn't tell
him I knew it. I looked at it. I said,
"What's an error in terraform? Like,
where's the red?" He says, "There's no
red." I said, "Well, then there's no
error." you did it right. Like it was it
was kind of a fun thing for me to do. I
had to correct his thinking because he
was in panic mode, right? So I was like,
"Okay, I was gonna correct how you
think."
>> So he panics when he did everything
correctly.
>> Yeah, that's good. I like that. Like
that's an easier correction for me to
do.
>> You
>> Hey, super quick question. Um, somebody
said they were getting recruited by
Warner Brothers. What's the story behind
that? I recruited by Warner Brothers.
>> Yeah,
>> I already worked at Warner Brothers. I
have I have to go talk to Serge about
it. Yeah, I already worked there. I know
what their network has. It's AWS
>> to do You're right. To to do platform
engineering, AI, the stuff we're doing
in class.
>> Hey, Rob. Rob, whenever you see the
police, what you do?
>> What brother?
>> What? What does it have reference to the
class?
>> Somebody just said it. Somebody just
said it. Say it again.
>> When you see the police, you want a
brother.
>> Oh, you Oh my Oh god. Oh,
thank you.
>> Hey, Theo. Theo Theo. Couple years ago
back when you was getting on me, would
you tell me about that quote that you
tell me about suffering? I got to do
what? Could you could could you say that
that quote you told me a couple years
ago?
>> Suffer more. I remember what it was.
>> Yeah, that's basically it. But you
didn't say it like that. But
>> suffering is a foundation of success.
Something like that.
>> Yeah. You told me that that if I really
want to make this work, I I got I got to
suffer more. I got to suffer more
because I was I was putting in work, but
I really wasn't doing what I needed to
put in.
>> Okay. Think right now it's it's 9:00.
What? 9:00 here. All students till 9:30
here. I'm going to be up another four
hours working. I'm going mainly be
studying.
And I'm your teacher and I have jobs,
but I'm still doing I'm still putting in
work. I I have to do theoretical
work right now with AI platform
engineering things I haven't done
before. So that's why I have my books. I
have to go into Python and make new
agents,
try to figure things out. I got to do
MCP server again.
I got to do MC server security.
So I mean, oh, Kong, we're implementing
Kong API for Kubernetes from the company
and they're going to give it all to me.
Where do we do Kong? Kubernetes class.
Same stuff.
No difference.
So the guys in your class, they just got
to work on it. If they don't
get a body back, throw them over and
they're care.
>> See,
see, I think Jules said it perfectly in
his uh in his post. So
>> yeah, I like the post. Sounds good.
>> So
>> it's good and aggressive. Y'all haven't
seen it, then
this is what it is. Want to be candid.
Anyone struggling to get it. So, so to
your guys, Omar, that you're referring
to that are struggling to get it, fair.
You need to walk in not for anyone but
yourself and your future. The class is
not easy.
I will say this is like M's level
information.
And if you're
I'm not going to dunk on anyone who, you
know, went to high school, didn't go to
college, doesn't matter to me. But
there's but if if if you you know if you
got out of high school and then you
started working you know physical labor
and then you start want to switch a
career to this end up with Theo. Yes,
it's going to seem hard because there's
a level of abstraction that
is is more or less an invisible barrier.
And that's and that's fair. But everyone
can climb up to that invisible level and
then get there. And as of late, we've
been giving people routes to to get to
that level of abstraction
through CPG, but people are hesitant to
go. That's another story. But whatever.
The class is not easy, but simple. Do
what the teachers say. Homework, study,
read, use AI sparingly.
Use AI sparingly.
Develop the ability to understand what
you're trying to solve and why. That's
part of the reason why I asked Theo the
systems design question because
we f because I'm I'm f I'm noticing that
people right now are focusing more on
the technological tool what they're
using as opposed to what problem are you
trying to solve for and how can you
apply your solution to a company that
may have that problem. or how can you
sell that how can you sell your solution
to a company that doesn't even know they
have that problem
like
for I I'll give you know an example of
you know Kong API or API gateway who
needs who needs a gateway
well if you're just thinking of hey I I
need to learn Terapform I need to learn
this I need to learn that you're
thinking of API gateway is just another
thing in AWS that you don't really need
to worry about because FO hasn't taught
yet. But if you're thinking of okay,
what does a system need and or how how
can a cloud communicate with each other?
How does the infrastructure stand up? If
you want to use ser if you want to use
servers, then you're going to use EC2s.
That's pretty much easy because you you
can do the load balancer. But if you
want more speed, if you want um a
different type of security, if you don't
want as much o uh uh server overhead,
then you then you're going to head into
microservices
and server OS, which means you have to
start using different communication
channels. Cool.
What is the what is the uh what's the
piece of of infrastructure that could
help you balance the uh the channels
that b balance the balance the what's a
what's a load balancer for a serverless
or a microservices application you need
the API you need API gateway in order to
in order to limit the amount of
information that comes in direct it to
where it needs to go to uh protect from
DDoS so on so forth. So now API gateways
now API gateway becomes a part of the
solution but if you're just but if
you're just thinking about oh Theo told
me this then told me that then told me
that and I'm going to focus on what Theo
told me. Theo what Theo tells you is
good but it may be limiting yourself.
So that systems design and especially
with the um with with this guy, the
Atlassian guy. I'm going to assign this
for homework.
>> I I read that. I was laughing. I I
thought that was like
>> Oh my god.
>> Like like I want you guys to understand
that this guy with that video that he
put up and I'll put it into the
homework. This guy's video, it basically
can get him hired anywhere he wants to
because he literally described
Atlassian's entire infrastructure like
AWS infrastructure in like 40 minutes
and you can replicate it and and the the
ease in which he goes through
everything. Now again, it it's it's
eight years of experience. He built it
from scratch. He knows what he's doing.
But but if you could describe yourself
half as good as him, then you'll be at
Jules's level within 6 months.
Like the the bar is not that I'm telling
you guys, the bar is not that high. It's
it's really not. Okay? It's it's really
not. Like the only reason why we're
having issues is because no one no one
has chosen to create a um a consulting
company and that's not calling anyone
out but that's just the the nature of
where we are right now as a group.
That's number one. And number two,
Indians have kicked down the door and
are trying to get everyone in. And
again, if you and you know, anyone here
can go bar for bar with an Indian on
what they need to do and and being
creative and finding a solution. But
again, that's another story.
Okay. I'm not the best engineer for my
cohort. Originally, class three, he
dropped out, came back for class 5,
which was Miami. Oh, sorry, not which is
uh Atlanta part two. Um he's a hard
worker. Didn't give up. uh even when
frustrated, he kept pushing. Um had
valuable people who offered time to
help. So he knew he had efficiency. He
went over those people who who he knew
he could get some answers from. He
sought them out, got the information,
made it short, sweet, got the uh
absorbed what they were telling him, and
he ran with it. and he, you know, listed
a few there like Theo, Remo, Move,
Derek, whatever. And, okay, this is not
for anyone who wants the easy way to
make money.
You You're not a woman who can lay on
their back and and collect DNA samples
and $100 bills. Um, and well, you could,
but that's whatever. Walk in. How dare
you
>> lock in, get your search, understand
your cloud, understand Linux automation,
security
or whatever
niche skill you want. Okay. Um, deal
skill is Python. Sorry, Theo skill is
networking and security and now AI. But
you got you you got you got you like
once you get the cloud the Linux
security is a is a niche that you can
get into and then you could say hey I
can get paid off of this and they'll pay
me more because I know how to do this
thing. So everyone who comes into this
class is already started on that niche
path of security which pays well.
You can turn around in one year. Two, if
your schedule is already crammed. So 12
to 12 to 24 months. If someone wants
this, they can get it done. And it's
going to take failure. Jules failed 98
interviews until they got he got his
first role. He's had 260 and failed 75%.
Failure to gives you the bare path
through learning what doesn't work. And
you will fail on the job, too. You just
document it and get paid. If you want to
get paid to get stuff wrong, you're in
the right place. That's what it is. You
You get paid to try stuff out and come
up with a new solution.
It took him 18 months to get a job. I've
had more than two years of consistent
constant work, good pay, and I'm still
learning, failing, and persisting. And
now he gets to take his first vacation
in 10 years. So going into the summer,
work hard, be persistent, work with your
group, and be prepared to fail. That's
how you win. If they if Omar, you know,
you can send this to your guys, they can
see it already. If they don't if they
don't get if they this if this doesn't
resonate with them, then nothing that
any of us say will because then cuz
because I already know what their
mindset is. They're just going to say,
"Oh, well that's Jules. He figured it
out and that's where they lose because
we're no different. Cuz outside of
outside of what our mamas and papas
called us, we're no different than any
one of any one of each other. We're were
men in America in the West trying to get
this [ __ ] straight. If you can't find
and and people who came before us were
able to blaze a trail and then now we're
walking a semi-paved path. If they
can't, if the guys who are questioning
still have questions or still can't get
it straight after this, I mean, nothing
that we say is going to fix it, that
means they need to go to talk to culture
clinician or another mental health
professional or do some affirmations or
pray about it to the god of their
choosing and they need to seriously just
they they need they need to reset. I
don't know where it is, but I'm not
gonna tell you to go fix it for them,
Omar, because you've done what you
needed to do. You brought them here and
you give them the information. And if
they don't want to listen to you or if
they need if they want you to convince
them, then I'm not going to tell you to
go do that. You're that's not for you to
do that. That's on them.
>> Yeah, it's it really is. You You have to
let if they're not going to go with the
program that you have to let them slide.
just say, "Hey, look, keep on going."
There were a member in class two, you
know, the first class that failed was
class two and
the the people were thinking about
everything except for cloud.
It was very the only guy who really
thought about cloud was um Cam and Remo.
Those two got it. Almost everybody else,
they really weren't thinking about
there's touch and go.
Right. So, you have to again um you know
I I looked at class two. I was like,
"Okay, we're going to do it differently
now." And uh you just have to look at
the students and say like, "Hey, look,
you know, are you doing the work? Are
you doing the homework? Are you doing
there's plenty of examples of what's
going on inside the task. Um I got to
admit this is this a rather whack jobs
market. The country's at war, not happy.
You have inflation, you know, I mean
that some things are [ __ ] but at least
staying with your training program paid
for. Why would you not continue double
down on the studies, double down on the
work? That's what I'm doing. Um, again,
some of my designs I I've been working
for months with some of my designs with
Chad GT and we kind of just go back and
forth with different programming ideas,
how to add additional functionality. I'm
reading these various books. It gives me
gives me books to read like go out and
buy this that this is why I have so many
freaking books because I just I I like
books but it just say like you got to
get this, you got to buy this too. I
don't get it for free on PDF. If I go to
Amazon, buy the actual book, it's here
in the house, right? And I just
remember, I mean, it's like last week at
some point when I did the AKS, I put the
agent in there and I explained what
happened. It's been the long process.
You know, Tragic said, "Yeah, you're
Theo, you are an AI, what was it? You're
an AI
what AI platform security engineer.
That's how I should rationally talk
about myself from now on." I actually
fundamentally understand how to use AI
at the cloud. I was like, "Wow, AI told
me that I know what I'm doing." Okay,
you could be biased, but I wasn't even
asking for that. They were just talking
about various platforms and various
technologies. So, I'm bringing that the
the same methodology I'm bringing into
class. But I I also want to add that
Theo first even thought about AI
after
that that after when Jules came back uh
that class five conclave that's when
Theo even first considered doing AIO
offs. So if you want to put time on it
he's he's put he's been at this for two
and a half years.
>> Yeah.
So, are you willing to work? And so,
there there I remember um you know, a
year into it, he was driving himself
crazy
uh being laid off by jobs, having to
study TensorFlow and Cube Flow, and he
didn't understand this. This was 6.5 the
summer.
>> Yeah, I remember that. That was that was
horrible. Last summer,
>> right? Last summer, Theo was going
through he was studying AI and he was
like, "I don't know why I'm doing this
and I I don't know what what this is for
and and the jobs aren't coming and
people are bothering me and now I got to
go to Miami and pay for Obsidian and all
and all this BS, right? and he pushed
through it and now he can say he's an AI
platform security engineer and he's a
literal unicorn in the market and he he
finally he listened to me one of the
rare times he listened to me I got to
check if the sky is falling no sky is
not falling and he is now trying to
actually see if his skill set is worth
what what we've been saying which is
like it should at at the minimum 350 for
for a single row. But we'll see because
I know that it's possible and I know
that deal doesn't prioritize money
because ultimately we shouldn't. But for
people who are trying to get out of the
out get out of relative poverty, then
yes, people going to prioritize money.
So it's that's fair. But the my point is
Theo it took Theo time to do this. And
it took Theo consistency and like hey I
need to just continue on instead of try
instead of me just throwing my hands up
and say you know what effort I'm going
to double down on on uh Kubernetes or
I'm going to double down on DevOps and
I'm just going to wait for the market.
No, you kept kept pushing. So if Dio had
to do that and Dio even had to go to um
some of his students for help. Hey, how
do you even get this? How do you how
does this make sense? Help me make sense
of this AI stuff cuz I because like deal
like I conceptually don't get it and and
students help them. Yeah, there there
were a whole series of things I didn't
understand and because I was doing
machine learning. I didn't understand
like you do machine learning first then
you AI. AI is the actual application of
machine learning. So separate the two.
You can rent out machine learning by
using fundamental foundational models on
on the cloud. I was like ah ah I don't
have to do it all by myself. Like doing
machine learning something you do later.
Oh I get it. Okay, that took me a while
to understand and I I was going around
in circles. Um, but now, yeah, I mean, I
get it. Um, but then, uh, AI to to what
degree it was competent. That took me a
while to deal with once I saw how
competent it was though, how Oyama on a
small basis on EC2 and then touch Claude
how they could be used for aentic. I was
like, "Oh, I'm I'm down.
saying, "I'm good. Yeah, I understand
how it works." Um, but that took a long
long time. A lot of frustration. Me
reading books, me sitting here
very frustrated
saying, "Why the hell most of the time
thinking like I'm I'm just again I'm 53.
This whole process is happening right
when I'm turning 50 and above." And I'm
like, "Can I just have the cloud be the
main thing that I'm doing?" you know, I
go into my retirement like, do I have to
have this AI? I I just quit cloud native
in 2020. Like, why do I have that AI
right now? I don't want it. And the
amount of the learning curve has been
absolutely massive. It's just huge.
>> I'm good.
>> But now he's good. And now, like he like
Theo said earlier, now the job that he
just did AI for made him a made man.
Meaning he if as long as the as long as
Theo is willing to have them, they will
always have a job for Theo. Means always
be paid. So that so now he has a
retirement,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> So two two and a half years for the rest
of Theo's life. Do is that is that a
good trade deal?
>> Yeah, I mean uh I think how long did it
take? Okay, so for me to go cloud native
it took about four months for me to do
that. I had do I had to do intense study
but that was during um the pandemic. Uh
fortunately I had taken SANS courses
already so that that really helped out.
>> How long did it take me to go to Cisco?
I got my first Cisco job.
When did I want to start doing Cisco
again? It took about a year and a half.
>> That was easy.
>> Cisco jobs in my
Yeah. So that was February 20. Yeah. It
was It was about a year about a year and
a half
for me to get my first job. Forgive me.
My first IT job took a year.
Really? So that was a while. Um
the thing was is that once I got my
CISSP, all I did was get job after job
after job. Like I couldn't stop.
>> It's been non-stop ever since then. Um
AI took two and a half to three years.
And then if you were back in the classes
in the day, I was I was basically
dissing AI on a continual basis. That
was [ __ ] Um,
cloud. I laughed at cloud from 2014 to
until I saw what was coming. Then I I
went cloud native. So, six years I
laughed at cloud. I thought it was a
total joke. I was totally a data center
of only
>> Hey, I got I got a quick question about
your CISSP. Did you start doing
>> sock analyst in the beginning or did you
jump right into red team, blue team and
pin testing?
>> None of it.
No, I was a network security engineer.
I did firewalls and encryption VPNs.
>> I've been a network engineer since day
one basically.
What you want to know Theo's motivation?
>> Money.
>> Money and staying in that country cuz he
had a uh he had a chica.
>> A chica.
That's why I'm I'm trying to help DMA as
much as I can.
So, did anybody see Day's
um Facebook page?
Have anybody seen a story?
new.
>> Would anybody do that?
>> I have not.
>> Well, go look at his story because if
you look at his story, you'll see a Thai
woman who's got a kind of got a bulging
stomach.
>> Oh. Oh.
>> What do you guys think that means?
>> It's a reason for him to study some
more.
>> Yeah. We can notice that Day got his SSA
and security specialty at AWS before he
joined the class.
He got both of them while he was in um
the Netherlands like he was waiting to
pass his uh waiting for the class to
start.
>> I think he got security as well.
>> Yeah. No, he said security special. Got
to
he's been relentless.
All he wants to do is get a job so he
can support his girlfriend and get
married to her and have a baby.
That's it. I highly That was my
motivation. I mean, I had this beautiful
Japanese woman. I needed more money. The
requirement, the ideal was 1 million yen
per month to get married. I got my
CISSP.
I went from what was I at?
700,000.
I think I was at 7,000
>> whatever it was. But then you like
double you doubled your salary like
walking over the street or something.
>> Yeah. I was like I was 600,000 yen a
month and then I went to 1 million yen a
month when I got out of this. The
difference was that I was working three
jobs to get 600,000 yen a month.
>> Now you're one and making one and making
Yeah.
>> So I was very happy about that.
actually thrilled. So, uh, you know, if
you put the time in, you know, it's it's
worth it. I mean, it's just it's so much
better. That's
>> Yeah, it's
>> because because you just because like
ultimately you like you guys are just
dealing with minutia at that point.
Small tweaks, small requests that
they're asking for. Oh, can you build
this? Okay, I may need like two, three
weeks on this. All right, cool. I got
the code already.
>> Yeah.
>> Hey, Theo.
>> Hey, Theo. Whenever Whenever you got
that 600K, is this what you did?
>> 600K? No, no,
no, no. And the exchange rate at that
time was 110 to the dollar. So, I didn't
think I was rich at all because the
requirement was 1 million
and I needed to um I mean I wanted to
get married and I knew how much rent was
and everything else into Tokyo. So,
I I wasn't stopping at 6 600,000. No,
not at all.
>> I didn't think I was real. When I got to
one, I I relaxed.
>> I remember that day. I got to 1 million
and then uh what happened?
I I married my fiance
six weeks later
>> about the ring and everything.
>> Well, she already had the ring. I got
it. She already got
>> and then
>> had the apartment. And right now he's
debating as to whether you should be
paid
25 times what made him married his marry
his fiance.
>> Yeah. I Yeah. I mean no I want No, that
was 1 million yen per month.
>> Right
>> now basically I would like to have 2.2
million yen per month minimum.
Uh but to be honest like if I
that ISO
>> 01
>> that that job is like 300 325
>> that's more like it
>> it's on that's on the page but I get it
>> well what is that what is that 2.2 two
million yen transfer to US.
>> Don't translate over to US.
>> Oh, you're not spending You're not
spending the money in the United States.
You're spending the money in Japan.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Exchange rate doesn't matter.
>> Okay. Gotcha. Gotcha.
>> Yeah. It's something you when we're in
Japan, we have to educate the foreigners
on this is that you're in Japan, you're
in yen. You have to think about yen
terms. It's what we're dollar isn't here
yet. It's all yen. So what we do to make
life easier, if you want to do exchange
rate, everybody informally uses a 100
yen to the dollar because the exchange
rate fluctuates so much that it could be
like in two years it could be like 70
yen to the dollar or 80 yen to the
dollar or there's 120 right now it's
like 150 to 160. So it fluctuates so
much. Just don't think about the
exchange rate.
>> See,
>> you don't in terms of dollars.
>> And and just to be clear, the average
monthly salary for guys for men is
roughly
350 to 450,000 yen.
>> Oh, no. No. Oh, no. I would say 250
right now.
>> You're including gig workers?
>> Yeah. Yeah. 250,000. Yeah, the economy
is suffering today. So if I make 2.2
million yen a month, roughly speaking, I
would be making nearly 10 times monthly
the average monthly salary of a Japanese
worker almost
a Japanese man. That's where we want to
be. 10x
>> 10x. So yeah, you guys are on the right
way. I don't know why you would Japan
doesn't have [ __ ] compared to what the
United States has right now.
Not even close. I can't believe how bad
it is. I mean, I thought it was bad at
AWS. Right now, this in this company, I
can't believe it. This is treacherous.
Um, so you guys have the opportunity.
Go study. Just go study. I start asking
you guys, did you guys buy this book?
like your students just ask them did you
buy PieTorch a practical guide
>> or or just ask them hey like what book
have you what book are you reading what
pulled up a book what book have you
bought in physical something like that I
don't know
>> there's the what I'm what I'm finding
Omar to be honest is that there are guys
who aren't qualified to do um secretary
or data entry work in the office.
>> That's how low they are coming in.
>> And I don't I I've asked them like how
are they organizing their computers and
they might have just bought a computer
for the company for the course. It's the
first time they've had a computer.
That's a low level. That's on them.
>> Mhm.
>> If I would go to Japan and say that
there are people in America who don't
have computers, they start laughing like
how is that even possible? America's the
number one country in the world.
>> Yeah. I thought I thought everybody had
computers if they were born after 95 in
the '9s, early 2000s. I I would figure
everybody cuz we didn't, you know, our
generation, we didn't have them until
early 90s. But I figured the the
millennials, the genu genesis, they
would all be up on it. But I'm realizing
it's actually the opposite. Like they
>> It's the opposite. Yeah.
>> Yeah. They they're telling me that
they've never used a computer before.
and they were born in 95
uh 99
200 something. I'm like there's no way.
But and it's a way. It's away. Yeah. So
>> well but the thing about it like if
you're born after if you're born after
96 97 you're accustomed to be using your
phone for everything.
>> You never you never really worried about
having to you know interact with a
terminal, a keyboard, a mouse. You just
>> just have it point and quick for
everything. I have a iPad. I have a
tablet. I have a phone.
>> I have text. I have text to speech.
>> Take screenshots. I can I can text on
the on my phone. I can type it out on my
phone then and email to someone and it's
good.
>> You know, point click, right click,
>> you know, controls, whatever. Keyboard
commands. They don't
>> they ain't got that. That's
>> Yeah. Gooey. Gooey. Gooey. That was
easy.
>> That's That's why Single Way is there.
That's why a part a part of Single Way
is go do this typing test every single
week and keep your scores because you
need to be able to interact with this
endpoint in order to deploy this
infrastructure. You can't do it on your
phone.
>> Mhm.
But
>> yeah,
>> again gotten a version to single A and
or CPG or whatever. Okay.
>> So what I what I always say this there
are three requirements to be in the
class. You have to be a black man. Yeah.
You have to have a pal to be willing to
do the work. All right. Now there are
I'm assuming that you are a part of a
first world country.
So part of being a first world country
is that you know how to use like
Microsoft Word and you can write your
ideas on the computer. Well, if you
can't do that, as far as I'm concerned,
you failed first world country living
and there are guys who are in the class
who are on that who are on that failure
level.
So we have to deal with them in CPG,
right? And that's that's as far as I'm
like, "Hey, look, that's not on me.
Like, that's some that's somebody else
somebody else is doing that." So, and
those and those kind of guys come and
say like, "Well, what about the basics?"
I'm like, "No, man. You should have
already known that before you got into
the class. Let's assume that you know
that. I mean, for heaven's sakes, you
don't have to know you don't have to
know technology.
>> But I knew how to type on a typewriter
when I was 12.
>> They don't know how to type, Theo. They
really don't know how to type. I like I
said, I keep
>> I tell them in the group I tell them in
the group I said that that that Theo's
pretty he don't explain a lot of stuff
because they say, "Well, he doesn't
explain this and explain that." Like
because he already assumes that you know
how to do it.
>> Um and that's multiple things that I got
to explain to them. I was like, "He
doesn't break it down
>> and I got to break it down during the
group because he thinks you already know
it." you know things like git and you
know basic CLI commands and um
>> well I don't even require that think
think well the CLI commands those are in
the documentation
>> right so for the in the repos I put that
information there
>> you notice that my documentation I don't
have any git commands
>> no
>> because you already assume they already
know it
>> no I don't
>> I got to walk them through it I got to
walk them through it
I don't have that. That get that part is
called Aaron
>> and that's for homework submissions.
That's it.
>> Mhm.
>> I don't actually go into get until much
later.
Every class is like that. It's I don't
go I it's much much further down the
line. That's when actually get becomes
important. You you need to have get in
relation to Jenkins.
That's when I That's when I'm like,
"Okay, yeah, I we need to get serious."
But only So, if you're not doing they're
not doing Jenkins, I don't assume that
they know Git.
>> Well,
well, when I took over as group leader,
I assumed everybody knew knew knew HTML,
just basic HTML and Markdown. I did. And
I was I was given a rude wakening on
that because I got guys saying, "What's
HTML and Markdown?" And I'm like, what
do you
>> Okay, so for uh CPG, that's part of CPG.
Remember,
>> in cloud, HTML markdown is not a part of
the curriculum.
>> But they got to document. They have to
document on the job.
>> Well, documentation is, but documenting
HTML is not part of it. That HTML is is
a is a language. Now, markdown
markdown's cool, but you can do the same
in a in a text document. Same thing.
Yeah.
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah. For the most part,
like you're just writing on Confluence,
like what Kevin is saying, you're
writing on Confluence or something like
that. So, I'm more concerned that you
know how to use bold
>> um in in Word, like you know how to
write a document in Word or you're going
to like Open Office like that and you
can actually write down your idea
>> like with your hands. You're not
dictating it.
>> That that is more important because when
you go to the office, you're not Nine
times out of 10, you're not gonna have a
microphone that's going to do voice
translation, voice dictation for
documentation.
That's mean just a major thing. You need
to know how to spell. You need to spell
check. But those are things you should
have known by the time you're 18 years
old anyway in your personal country.
>> Right. Right.
>> So just Excel, right? Microsoft Word and
Excel at least. Right. Just the basic
Microsoft suite stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Outlook. Outlook.
>> Outlook. Yeah. I would assume that you
know how to Yeah. You know how to use
email client things like that.
>> Yeah. Or they don't know. They don't
know it.
>> They don't know.
>> So yeah, if if they don't know that,
that's like, okay, that's on you guys.
>> Yeah. This
>> Yeah. Like do you Okay. Do you know how
to use a banking app?
So in the beginning when students didn't
know how to use folders,
>> what do you think the first question I
thought was?
>> What? File Explorer, Windows Explorer,
>> folders.
physical folders or or
>> folders and file explorer.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. He's talking about
file explorer. I'm just making sure.
Okay. Yeah. Windows or file explorer.
Yeah. They don't understand that either.
Theo. They don't understand.
>> What do you think?
>> Absolute pass. Absolute pass. Relative
pass. They don't understand that.
>> What do you think? If you don't know how
to use a folder, what's the first
question do you think I had?
>> What's that?
>> Do you have any pics of women on your
computer?
Right. And if you do,
>> my thought
>> if you do have pics, where are they?
>> Yeah. Where are they?
Because you, what you just said to me is
that you don't organize pics of women on
your computer.
>> They'll just put on their desktop.
They'll just put on their desktop.
>> But
they But they but they know where But
they know if they want to go find it,
they know where to go on the side.
They if they know if if they know that
if they click on this on this icon right
here and then they go on the shortcuts
on the side they will find it. So so
they know at a small level what folders
are. They know
>> in the preview pane in the preview pane
in file explorer
>> preview pane's on the right quick access
is on the left.
>> Mhm.
So they know, so they know if they go on
the quick access and they go to
documents or downloads, then they can
find what they're looking for. They know
how to do that.
>> They may not connect the fact that it's
called the folder and file structure
compared to, oh, I just know how to go
to my downloads folder. Going if they
know how to go to the downloads folder,
they know what to do. They they know how
to do this. And all we're doing is is
expanding on what they know how to do.
>> So if they don't know, if they genuinely
don't know, then I have to look at them
as being backwards.
And if they would go into any male group
anywhere, gym, locker room, bar,
anything, and they say all the photos of
women, I keep it on my desktop and I
don't keep it organized, any folder
structure. They would be the the mockery
of the entire bar. Every single male
right then and there be like, "What the
[ __ ] How can you possibly do that? How
did you go through adolescence and do
that? How? I don't get it. I don't
know."
>> Right. Right. Because it's like, "Oh,
well, you just kept all your you just
kept all the hot girls on your desktop.
Okay. What happens when your girl sees
it?"
>> Yeah. Exactly. So yeah, that was that
was me. So the first like my 386 that I
had it was connected to the internet.
Once it was connected to the internet, I
had a requirement to have folders real
quick. It was very it was I had the eyes
check
know what was going on in my computer.
>> I got ate up one time from a girl. I had
a cuz I had a I had a chick on my
wallpaper. On my wallpaper. Not the
screen saver. I had this chick from
school on my wallpaper. I got my ass
kicked for that to take her off.
>> Right. My dad did not understand folders
and I looked at him and I was like, "Oh,
you're a Neanderthal."
>> Cuz I was like, "I know what you're
doing on your computer." I was I was
being a good son. I didn't tell him that
I knew what was going on. I was very
quiet about it, but I was discreet. But
I looked at I was like, "I know what
you're doing with that cash. I know what
you're doing here. I know you're doing
there. I could figure it out." again
downloads very quiet didn't say anything
about
>> right so if you don't know that so I
want say when I did that that was in
>> no I got you theo but what I'm saying is
I try to press press more CLI stuff so
that when they interview
>> and they and they struggle moving around
the guey
>> you're not going to be you're not going
to be doing CLI in the interview
>> well on on certain uh second well I just
had a guy he on the second um round they
actually had him do some hands-on stuff
he told me and he struggled.
>> So
>> So if there that okay that's a technical
interview if there
>> in the second room.
>> Yeah. So that he should have a list of
CLI commands on his computer
>> and they they can't do anything about
that every time. I always do that. I
have my list. I tell them I have a list
of things.
>> But he he did good in the first round.
He did good in the first round, but the
second round is when when he struggled
on the on the technical side doing the
CLI, just basic CLI commands,
>> but he couldn't remember him.
>> What what commands was he working with?
Was he working in the Terraform as a
language? Was he working with Python?
What do you say on his resume?
>> He was in Git Bash. He they just wanted
to see if he knew the basics. That's it.
They
>> of just navigating.
>> Yep. Just navigating basic CLI commands.
They wanted to see if he could CD CD dot
dot um uh nut touch uh name files,
rename files. I'm telling you, man,
that's they're not asking for too much
in these interviews. They just want to
see if you just know the basics. And he
couldn't do that.
>> So,
>> and he couldn't do that. So, he didn't
he didn't get the gig. So,
>> so that's so if he's been through this
class,
>> this is why I say people that cash on
the rewind,
>> people that don't do the web, people
that just want to absorb, just want to
watch it and then say, "Oh, Theo did it,
JJ did it, Logan did, so I'm good."
Okay. Until it was time for you to do
it. And then now you struggling.
>> Yeah. because this is stuff that we had
to do in order to do terraform.
So, I mean it I hope that he learns from
this.
>> Yeah.
>> Because you you have to you have to take
L's like that in order for you to to
learn.
>> Oh, he knows his basic CLI commands now.
Top 10 CLI commands. We already went
through it, so he knows it now. So,
>> yeah. So, a lot of those guys will not
learn the commands until they fail
something like major like that,
>> right?
>> It's very normal. Again, why I got hyper
before on on uh what was it Cisco was
because CCNA and CCDA required that at
the time.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I knew commands, right? Um so, yeah,
you don't have to have those commands so
much for of course the AWS test,
>> but it's assumed that you know those,
right? So yeah, there's when I'm
teaching again, I teach terraform in the
beginning. Sometimes I teach some
lessons, sometimes I don't. That's
usually why I usually go to the
graphical interface first. But then I do
teach touch later on. I do teach echo,
right? BI do that as well,
>> right?
>> But but just as an addition, that's day
one of CPG,
>> right?
>> Yeah, it is. That's why I encourage most
guys that go through CPG or Huru Ross
teach all of that stuff. They teach
absolute. I look through their
curriculum. They teach absolute and
relative file structures,
>> which most people don't know what that
is. And they should know that. They
should know what absolute and relative
file structures mean. But I know there's
guys in the group right now that are
listening. They're like, "What the hell
is he Omar talking about?" But they do.
But but they teach you that in CPG
absolute and relative file structures
very necessary. It's very foundational,
but I noticed that a lot of guys, they
struggle during the walkthroughs with
you guys cuz they don't understand file
structure. They struggle with it. You
know, when they when y'all do the
walkthroughs, they don't they don't
understand absolute and and and and
relative file path.
>> You don't need that. You don't need that
actually for the walk through.
>> Well, I'm saying they I'm telling you,
>> you don't need to know that. You just
need to go to a folder and understand
that this is where your folder is. This
is how you open up
>> Visual Studio Code and they say execute
Terraform and Python,
>> right?
>> That's it.
>> You could do the work.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. They they could
they could they could use the guey, but
but who in Ross they they teach them
they they teach that in the curriculum
and they teach them how to do the um all
the basic stuff. So, if they just run
through the CPG,
>> then when they come back to the regular
classes, they'll be prepared. they won't
be just, you know, all over the place
just on a on a on a on on a basic
function.
>> So, so okay. So, let me then let me ask
you a question then. So, this is another
time. So, you brought you brought up
these guys, right?
>> These guys who are, you know, worried
and they're questioning the path.
How many give me a percentage of those
guys who are who are speaking to you.
How many of them are in CPG right now?
>> None of them. None of them.
>> Oh,
>> no.
>> They skipped. No, no, they skipped it.
No, no, they skipped it. I don't think
they think they need it. When I tell
everybody, I'm like, man, y'all y'all
should peep your head in. We had a
couple of guys that were in our group
that that started off back in back in
back in September, group seven, class
seven. They were in the field. a couple
of guys that were in our group that were
in the field
>> and they saw what what Theo had to
offer. These were cis admin guys that
are in the field and they took Single A.
They said, "Man, I need Single A."
Because a lot of cuz they do a lot of
things at their job that um you know,
it's like it's like once you could you
could get into your job and you could
get comfortable. And so they was like,
"Man, I need to go back and learn some
stuff." And they took Single A back in
what? October when y'all first announced
it. When did y'all first announce it?
>> October,
>> something like that.
>> Single A. No, it was um April.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm talking
about this go around now. Class. I'm
talking about
>> the September.
>> Yeah. So, I had a couple of guys,
experienced guys go back, run through
Ross and Ahuru, and it only took them
about three, four weeks, and they came
back in our group. They was like, man, I
needed that. These were guys that were
in the field that learned a lot from
from Ross and Ahuru because they just
they didn't use it every day on their
job. They they doing a lot of highlevel
stuff at their CIS admin stuff using a
guey, clicking and dragging, not
automating.
They're doing they're doing manual
backups as a CIS admin. I'm like, why
aren't you automating it, man? Well, I
don't I don't I don't know how to do it.
and they're getting paid hundred
something thousand dollars a year and
doing everything manual as a CIS admin.
>> So, so I just So, thank you. So, a guy
who's making over 100K
understands that he needs to fill up
that skill set and go to CPG.
>> Yes. And a and a huru taught him how to
do do bass scripting.
>> Ahuru taught him how to do bass
scripting in single A. It wasn't CPG
yet. It was single A.
>> Right. And so that's why I give shout
outs to Uhuru. I'm like, "Thank you."
And he came back. Yeah. Knock knock
automate now. And it helped him out on
his job.
>> So So if it was good enough for a dude
making six figures already,
>> but it's not good enough for the dudes
who are in dire straits not making six
figures in your group,
>> then that tells you it's not the it's
not the the content. the content
certified by people who are already in
the industry.
>> Yeah.
>> But then the people who don't want to do
it are the ones who are struggling you.
>> Yeah. I I got I got I got I got I got
over 10 years in the industry
as a tech lead. Me I got over 10 years
in the industry as a tech lead. And when
I met Theo and Theo gave all this stuff
to me. I didn't know cloud when I met
Theo. I was like man I got to go back
man. I had to go back and learn relearn
stuff cuz I was in the trucking business
for 10 years. So, I'm I'm being
transparent. We didn't have the single A
at the time, but I went back I I think I
told the I took a couple of classes at
the junior college here in Dallas,
just basic computer classes. Right. And
that that's what got me up to speed.
This was after cuz when Theo started
throwing all that stuff on me, I was
like, "Oh man, I don't even remember."
Well, I remember it, but not enough to
the part where I was efficient. So,
that's when I when I when I took a
couple classes at the junior college cuz
we didn't have single A yet.
>> And that's and then uh and that's how I
got my my refresher in.
>> That was all of 2023 and half of 2024.
But when I did that at the junior
college here,
>> particularly in the beginning, a great
deal of the class is just copy and
paste, clicking. That's all you're
doing. We don't do any scripting
anymore.
>> I only bring in scripting as an
additional part in order to like
validate things. But the scripts are
made. You have to run that. That's it.
>> So I don't require that kind of
programming and it's not necessary for
>> AWS cloud job particular. What is
necessary is DevOps
>> and there isn't any bash script. No, no.
Well, there's not. You can do it, but
there's no bash scripting in there,
though. Python script is there.
Although, it does make things easier if
you do do it. Um, so
>> Log just posted that he said it's very
necessary for him to learn Python
scripting and he put it on the Facebook
timeline. So,
>> I it but you're talking about senior
level. You're actually talking about you
don't to get that first job 150,000. No.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm just telling what he
posted.
>> So I mean right now I'm not doing Python
scripting. I am doing Python for aentic
AI and in the AI class yes there will be
Python for aentic AI. There's no way I
can get around it. I have to teach that.
>> But to be honest I mean for a lot of
those lot of positions no. Um if you
accept a position which does require
Python okay cool you know that's what
you wanted to do. the same way I usually
don't do a lot of databases, right? Um
you also Terraform is what's necessary
that that's why there's a Terraform part
of the class where if you do Terraform
that's declarative and not it's not not
has anything to do with bash scripting,
>> Python scripting. Yeah, just basically
point and click and so that's the things
that are necessary to get the job that
I'm telling you about. Yes, those are
things you have to learn that's in the
class. If you want to do additional,
cool. But even at that point, I'm like,
I don't know where it's going to be
impacting you on the cloud, maybe you
take a certain kind of job. Yeah. My
issue with bash scripting is again my
personal feeling
>> the closer you're getting to lots of
bash scripting, the closer you're
getting to an E2 and a red ocean.
So I tend to say you want to stay away
from that.
The architecture,
security, dev sec ops, devops,
all of that is standard. It's very
stable
and it doesn't require an aircraft
build.
>> So what's the top three skills you would
need for the dev sec ops stuff?
>> It's a class Jenkins, Python,
>> and knowledge of the cloud. you know
there's design
>> yes designed you know
>> that's this is all a part of the class
so so I don't mind when like like again
I I straight out told everybody I don't
do front end right
>> the reason why we do the user script do
you know why the reason why we do the
user script
>> because you don't do front end
>> no
guys need guys need to see it
>> well yeah I'm actually testing whether
or not somebody can follow instructions.
>> Oh, okay.
>> That's the whole point of it.
I'm giving them easy things to do that
they can see, as Rob said, and I'm
trying to see if you can follow
instructions.
>> That's the That's the test. That's all
it is is point and click. Drag this over
here. Drag this over there. That's it.
>> Copy paste. Point click. Copy paste.
>> That's it. So, yeah. So like again my
when I do Armageddon the first lab for
Armageddon is always copy paste. Are you
paying attention?
>> And if you're saying like I have to know
this, I have to know that. I have to
know like nope hell you don't
>> just process copy and paste.
>> No, I like I like the new curriculum
you're doing because it it really shows
if people are paying attention. I
noticed that in the first one. So you'll
put obvious mistakes in there and then
and then nobody will call it out so you
know that they're not really paying
attention. So
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I like how you do that. So
>> So the I don't want people to be
thinking that they have to know
everything. You don't. You have to
choose your balance.
>> I don't teach SQL.
>> Why do you think database is a devil?
Why do you think database is the devil,
Theo?
>> Because it goes into a really deep hole
and then you have to worry about the
connections. Gota worry about security.
You gota worry about
>> Yeah.
>> Got to worry about all these things and
Theo's a security guy, so you don't
worry about all these things. The only
the only thing that Theo actually goes
into depth with a little bit, but I
don't think he
>> the only thing the only thing that Theo
has to go into depth with
>> which he may not want to is Kubernetes
cuz
it's another esoteric system that you
have to learn that's that's on top of
the cloud infrastructure you're already
building.
>> Right. But technically you we don't
it's not all the way necessary but if
but if you want but it became necessary
be through agentic AI like now we need
now you need to know Kubernetes in order
to say hey I can do AI stuff because AI
runs best within the within that cluster
but before that he was like um it's it's
optional you can do it if you want to
but it was optional once this once AI
started taken over the market then it
became non-negotiable.
>> But but Rob, if you do do the database
manual setups and all of that, yeah,
you're correct. But there's so many
abstraction layers right now with
database. I mean, like MongoDB for
NoSQL. I mean, that stuff is abstracted
away.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Do you know who you're going up against
when you're doing database?
>> What as far as job opportunities?
>> Yes. the in the people group.
>> No, I never I never even I'm doing it
I'm doing it independent.
>> Yeah, I'm doing it independent. So,
>> you're going up against Indians
directly.
>> Right. Right. Right.
>> Okay. That's not a battle that I'm
willing to face to do.
>> Yeah. Red ocean.
>> Especially at it's red ocean. Especially
at that price point. I'm not going to do
it. Impossible.
>> So, I would rather the the DB be Indian
and then I come in and do the security
for the DB. I'm good. I got you. I got
you. I was just saying that a lot of it
is abstraction abstraction layers right
now. Databases now.
>> Well, you can the class is going to be
deadly. That's why I don't do it.
>> Well, even with the abstraction deal,
you know, it's also the cost level.
>> How like even if you're going to extract
away from the cloud,
>> what's the value? What's the what's the
added value in terms of like your bot
what's the added bottom what what is
added to your bottom line if you do uh
database and you know that's that's
where you start say all right what's
what are they paying for database on the
market what are they paying for cloud
database admins on the market
>> I have no idea I haven't even checked so
>> well
that then I would say that's something
for research down the road
>> who who's the guy who's the guy that
does the database that you send people
to. Theo, what's um
>> Subzero?
>> Subzero. Subzero. What does he say about
database? He teaches it.
>> Whatever he says about database, I I
don't know. I I haven't taken his class.
Um
>> Oh, okay. Okay.
>> That's his thing. Like that's all he
does. So, if you're if you're just
hardcore and that's all you do is
database,
>> okay, then probably go up against
Indian. But you're gonna have to be like
really hardcore against these guys
because yeah, you get I've told other
classes, you get a guy who's done
database for the last like 10 years.
He's 25 years old.
>> He can do Oracle.
He's a virgin. He has a master's degree
in it. Yeah. I'm not going against him.
>> No, I got
>> Yeah, it's a trade red ocean. There's no
way. I'm like, "Okay, got it, bro. Got I
I get you got 12 hours. You know, I'm
just going to stay over here, do my
thing
>> because I know I'm going to be
outclassed by him." The same guy with
Java developers. Although with that
video I just saw like, "Okay, maybe
we're not so bad." Um, so yeah, got Java
developer, same thing. 25 years old,
PhD, been doing it for the last 15
years.
>> Virgin hasn't gone to a party, never
barely even eaten cake. That's it. It's
all It's always done. Like,
>> I I I give you credit on the Red Ocean
stuff, man. I I wasn't I wasn't paying
attention to to that kind of stuff early
on, but
>> um you know, you don't realize who
you're going up against. Exactly. You
don't know who you're going up against.
So, you I give you a lot of credit on
that cuz
>> So, that's why like when the guys start
doing databases or or Java, I always say
only do it if that's what you're called
to do and like this is 100% what you
want to do. Same thing for Cosmos DB and
Azure. I hate Cosmos. Um, if you just
really want to do it like Subzero, like
that's what he does.
Yo, man, I respect it. That's what he
wants to do. Like, don't worry.
>> Is he doing Does Subzero does it as an
independent contractor mostly or as a as
a employee?
>> Go ask him. Don't go don't It depends. I
took his class. It depends on what the
market is saying.
>> Okay. Okay. He He does both.
Okay, got you. I figured he was I was
about to say I figured sub he man he got
to be double dipping because if it's red
ocean I don't think that he would just
just do that to himself. But like I said
I've never talked to him personally. No,
I did talk to him one time. I talked to
him one time.
>> He's hardcore who knows what he's doing.
>> Yeah.
So see if you're again you have to un
you have to think about the the fields
and where you can actually battle in the
American market. You have to be really
smart about it. Dax
>> Dax.
>> Cisco six. Cisco Cisco. Go ahead,
brother. Cisco,
>> if you're you're unmuted, but we may we
can't hear you. Your mic settings may be
>> Yeah.
>> needed edit.
>> Yeah, we can't hear you.
>> I just want to point out I didn't say
anything.
>> That That must be Darren. I don't know
if that's uh him doing that on purpose
or not.
>> Okay.
>> He might. Yeah, I'll check in with him.
Give me a second.
>> Okay. See if he has a question. Yeah.
But yeah, man. It's a good discussion
because, you know, like I said, the only
reason why I do my database thing is for
independent clients. Like I'm not trying
to get a job in database
cuz um there's a guy down in Houston
that told me the same thing Theo told me
about the database thing. He's been
battling Indians for
>> Yeah.
>> for 10 years. And I mean, he still has
his position. I don't know how, but I
guess it's because like you said, that's
his calling is data
>> because because on a individual to
individual
level,
Indians can't rock with a competent
engineer. The difference is that they
have power and numbers and then they
just overwhelmed and then they could get
you pushed out because they because the
few engineers that are good enough rise
up and then they could call the shots.
>> Yeah. So you just have to be aware of
it. That's all I mean just be smart. One
of the things I like about security is
that Indians very rarely like to do
security. Thank God. So it's it's easier
for me to operate. But I mean if they do
get really specialized and I'm like okay
well I have to work more and get paid
less. But that's the way it is. That's
how Indians are. So I have to go work
hard but I just usually don't specialize
someplace else but you have to
understand it. Um so again that's why I
choose my battles very carefully in the
class when I'm teaching. uh if you wish
to do something else in fine but
like for like the Cisco class right now
I'm having to decide where the battles
are going to be. I thought it was going
to be one way and now I'm like oh boy I
totally screwed that up.
>> What's the I'm curious what's the main
reason why you doing a Cisco class
because that's on on the traditional
side of it the Cisco hardware stuff
>> because there's guys who want to do and
I'm a Cisco guy.
>> Yeah. Okay. He was a Cisco guy. Cisco
guy originally. So CIS, so it was Cisco,
then it was security,
>> then it was cloud, now it's AI.
>> Okay. Okay. Cuz I don't know if Theo
remember telling them I I had the choice
back in 1999 and I chose novel. I I got
my novelt because Novell was the king at
the time. Well, it was they say Noville
was the king and so that's why I did the
novel administrator route, but it it
eventually just fell off. I I'm not sure
the whole whole story on Noville, Theo.
Do Do you know this whole thing? Because
I had gotten out the industry. What
>> Novelville got knocked out by 98.
>> By 98.
>> Yeah.
>> I got my ad I got my I got my C in uh
2000. 99 2000. So then you were wasting
your time. You should have gotten
Microsoft and specialized in Ethernet
routing.
>> Well, I did I did Mic No, I did
Microsoft NT4.0
and um and then noll just CIS. I didn't
do Cisco. I didn't do Cisco.
>> No was a waste of time. You should Well,
at that time you should have done
Microsoft and CCNA. You would have been
fine.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. Nobody led me to the CCNA, man.
I'm telling you, they did not. They led
me my my adviser. It was the It was the
adviser. It was the It was the college
advisor said no. Was it?
>> No.
>> I'm telling you what they I promise you.
They said no is the future.
>> Well, that's what they said. But you
know, by that by the time you got into
it, it was already
bound. It was already moot.
>> But that but that's why,
>> right?
>> See, but see, this is why, you know,
>> that's crazy.
>> For a while, people they need a mentor.
>> Yeah. And you know, that's why I'm happy
for Theo. That's also why
>> we we fight back so many times on the
guys saying, "Oh, we don't know what to
do." You have a mentor.
>> You have a we have a a Whitney of
mentors here. And if you don't know what
to do, it's not because there aren't
enough people to tell you like the
direction to go in. It's that you don't
want to walk.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Kirk was asking, "Was
my college advisor Aisha?" She was. It
was a black woman. It was
>> Yeah, that would make sense cuz
>> Oh, Lord.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I knew as soon as you said college
advisor,
>> but she was Listen, she was over the
over the IT thing though. Over the over
the CS
>> thing. Nobody Nobody at that
>> everything in the college.
>> Nobody should have been saying no.
>> Trust me. Totally.
>> We hear you.
>> Okay, great. I'm I'm sorry to interrupt,
guys. I just want to quickly speak on
Subzero's class because I took it.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Um, so what Subzero teaches, he teaches
specifically uh TSQL,
um, which is a version of SQL which was
derived by Microsoft. Um,
from what I understand about his class,
if you are just like Theo, if you are
serious about SQL, if you learn the
terminology, if you're able to describe
it inside and out, because you're an
English speaker, you have a significant
leg up in the job market. However,
Indians are going to be your main
competition. And the same way that they
are ruthless in the cloud is the same
level they're going to be ruthless to
keep you at a database. But in in the in
a similar vein, if you know it like the
back of your hand, like how you know
Terraform, like how you know the cloud,
you can get a database job. It is not
impossible, but it's difficult. Um the
the the type of SQL that he he teaches,
TSQL, is is extremely dominant in the
market. And so you're you're able to use
the the the the tricks and stuff uh from
that to do SQL and pretty much any other
kind of uh flavor and environment.
You'll just need to pick up some of the
basics of whatever that version of it
is. But he teaches it in a very similar
way as as Theo where once you understand
cloud principles, they're kind of
universal in whatever cloud environment
you want to go into. You just need to
learn the vocabulary. Same can be said
with TSQL. There's you just you learn
the vocabulary. It'll be slightly
different, but the core of it is the
same, but you have to be dedicated. You
got to show up every day to class. And
Subzero's uh courses move a bit faster.
Every he has classes multiple times a
week and every class is different. There
are no repeat classes. Every class is
different. So, he just goes through
stuff at an accelerated pace. He has
learning materials you can use to uh to
to to
essentially he has pre-done labs and
stuff you just need to fill out in order
to count as homework. You never push
anything to GitHub in his class. You
never you never log into a cloud
provider. It's very isolated in terms of
technology. He kind of treats um cloud
and
GitHub and a lot of the advanced tools,
Terraform, stuff like that like it's
magic. Um his thing is databases and
database accessories and he is a master
at that. He knows uh relational, non-
relational, he can break all that stuff
down. Um but if if you want to go for
databases, understand that is a
completely separate domain. He's going
to teach it like it's a separate domain
and he's not going to really connect it
with cloud at all. It's going to be it
its own thing. And if you take if if you
if you drill it like how Theo says for
us to drill cloud, you could you can get
a job as an English speaker, but it's
going to be difficult.
>> Yeah. So, I mean, I want to tell you how
that would work at the office. The
reality is that somebody like him would
be hired as the DB admin and then if the
DB were in the cloud, he would just say
like what the minimum requirement that
he needs for a database and then he
needs to have a login and I'd be like
cool. So I would just go to Terraform
and knock that out that knock that
environment out and I tell him how to
log in and then he does his stuff. I
don't even touch it up. It's like hands
off. I'm not I don't care. It says
that's the same way that Kubernetes is.
You have to do the underlying
infrastructure. You have to get the make
the pods work. And then once you get
that point, you're done. For the most
part, you the the developers do all the
work. You're just making sure the system
is running. That's it. It's a very
simple thing.
>> Uh we we can't say Kubernetes is simple.
It's get you get belly aching. So
>> doing all the microservices on there,
that's hard as hell.
>> That's actually a lot of work to get
those applications to work. Yeah, I'm
like, thank God I have to do that. But I
just have to Okay, the pod is working.
Okay, the namespace has this routing
working this way. Okay, cool. Got this
agent running. Okay, I see run real
time, runtime information. Cool. Okay,
yay. I'm done. You know, that's that's
all I have to do. so much easier.
They're dealing with multiple languages,
multiple environments, multiple
connection. I'm like,
I don't want to know. I don't want to
know.
I'm not yours. I'm just infrastructure.
That's it.
So, that's why I teach it in that way. I
teach enough so you guys get the
infrastructure support.
Um, anyway, good talk, guys. Um, please
enjoy. Uh, we're going to keep on doing
this in the class. Um, again, um, I'm
sending you guys up for Armageddon. If
you guys are smart, you might be able to
figure out what is going to be. You have
to give him a hint on.
>> Anyway, I will talk with you later and I
will see you on Tuesday. Thanks. Sorry.
Saturday.
>> No, you're you're you are having a
vacation. You're h you're not teaching
class.
>> Oh, that's right. It's a three-day
weekend. I forgot.
>> Exactly.
>> I actually wanted to teach.
>> So So no, what you're going to do is
you're going to teach yourself how to
scarf down a stuffed crust pizza from
Domino's from Pizza Hut.
>> Well, that's what I'm supposed to do,
too.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I get a I'm gonna get a
Chicago deep dish.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. I can do B. What do you got?
>> Hey, Theo. Yeah. I just wanted to let
you know I responded to your uh message
in the chat.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm looking at your your
repo. It actually looks really good to
be honest. So far
it's really professional.
So I'm going to keep on looking at it
and I need to I need to spend some time
because you spent a lot of time doing
that. It's not a five minute review. So
I need to keep on uh going through it.
But it's
it's exceptional. You've come a long
way.
So,
>> yeah, I see you doing well with it. I
might give you a few pointers to improve
it, but it's not, like I say, it's it's
not a critique. It's
you've done so great. I'll help you make
it even better like that.
>> I'm definitely ready for that. I
appreciate that. Really appreciate.
>> We'll we'll talk. All right. Um Yeah.
But I like I like what you've done. This
is It's actually crazy good. All right.
So, um, so last the last thing I'll say
again, you know, Omar, keep talking to
the guys
>> and keep if they're willing, you already
know what the game is. If they're
willing to listen to you,
>> then great. If they're not willing to
listen to you, then that's on them.
>> If you want a smoke show, then you need
to just let me know ahead of time. I'll
show up and I'll answer and I'll answer
any and all questions because at this
point this is ridiculous.
>> No, I got you. I got you. We good, man.
We going to be all right.
>> You're going to be all right. But if
again for them it's they their their
biggest enemy is is themsel.
>> Mhm.
>> That's that's for right now. That's my
message to them. Like their biggest
message is their biggest enemy is
themsself. And until they can make their
biggest enemy into their biggest
benefactor and contributor, they're not
going to change. So, it's a mentality
thing that they have to sort out with
themselves. It's not on you. It's not
any of us. You can lead the horse of
water. You can't make it drink. And
these guys are dying of thirst and
you're telling them where the water is
and they don't want to drink. You can't
you can't make that happen. Okay. So,
>> maybe I'll maybe I'll maybe
want to drink Kisha's battery acid. I
don't know.
>> Cool.
See, Neo just got indigestion.
>> Cool. Well, keep keep us updated on the
uh Vegas trip and all of that cuz I'm
going to be
>> making uh announcements for Vegas here.
>> It's happening. Pull up on Clar. Yeah. Y
do it. Anyway, guys, we'll talk to you
later. Okay. All right. Peace.